2 ans après Astérix et Obélix contre
César film troupier signé Claude Zidi
qui avait rassemblé en Gaule 9 millions
de spectateurs voici Astérix et Obélix
mission Cléopâtre cette fois derrière la
caméra il y a à la Chabat ex chef des
nuls et comédiens ils jouissent le rôle
de César Depardieu et clavier sont
toujours là dans les rôles titres mais
ils sont entourés de Monica Bellucci
Claude riche Édouard Baer Gérard Darmon
et très remarqué évidemment dans le rôle
de nobérobis l'architecte Djamel
Debbouze dont certains critiques ont
fait d'ailleurs le véritable est seul
héros du du film c'est lui qui doit à la
demande je le rappelle de Cléopâtre
construire en trois mois un palais pour
César un film qui par Toutatice a même
obtenu la Une des arts cupides et
l'appellation contrôlée d'oeuvre
pharaonique ce qui m'a semblé disons un
tout petit peu
excessif cela dit je n'ai jamais vu une
presse aussi unanime franchement c'est
bien foutu c'est rigolo c'est bien fait
mais la presse depuis une semaine me
semble désigner un objet que vous étiez
de nous raconter parce que dans le dans
la dans la sorte de chef-d'oeuvre que
qui n'est pas apparue si j'en juge par
en tout cas par vos confrères au premier
coup d'œil Michel Simon on vient de
parler du film de Taverny là ça m'a
stupéfait de voir que les mêmes gazettes
qui avaient été impitoyables journaux
les gazelle journaux qui étaient
impitoyable
bon plan chez Taverny c'est pas mettre
en scène voilà là d'un seul coup des
plantes tirés au corteaux un sens de
l'espace admirable alors j'étais mais
stupéfait parce que c'est procureur qui
sont d'une exigence absolue il trouvait
d'un seul coup à ce film des vertus
alors c'est vrai que par rapport au film
de zizi
pas non plus excessif je viens même même
Télérama qui n'est pas dans ton triangle
angle a fait un nombre de pages et de
déloges absolument incroyable on est
devant un produit Stone plus
incroyable
c'est un peu stupé parce que c'est vrai
que le film ce qui est amusant c'est un
film de configration par rapport au film
de zizi c'est-à-dire que et d'ailleurs
la façon dont il utilise deux par Dieu
et clavier qui sont un peu relégués
comme un peu des papilles de du vieux
cinéma français qui sont un peu terne
par rapport et la façon même dont ils
sont actifs et dont il se bougent etc
ils sont où ils sont encombrés etc et
évidemment c'est le triomphe de l'esprit
Canal+ enfin de la bonne époque
c'est-à-dire à l'époque ça marchait à
l'époque où ça marchait et le côté
branché avec des tas de référence au
tube de la radio à la musique à la bande
dessinée au cinéma avec des tas de clin
d'oeil de chaba qui sont qui sont très
amusants mais enfin j'ai pas trouvé que
ce film était le grand chef-d'oeuvre
annoncé j'ai trouvé même à part la
dernière la dernière demi-heure une une
bataille destruction de de monuments qui
est où il y a des idées assez marrantes
par exemple l'interruption un moment il
y a quelque chose qui va se passer qui
va être terrible en couple et on montre
une langouste un documentaire sur une
langouste à la place il y a des tas de
pour éviter de voir l'horreur de la
séquence bon il y a des idées comme ça
qui sont bonnes c'est vrai que celui qui
met tout le monde l'a dit c'est jamais
le début
n'y arriverai pas parce que Jamel
Debbouze qui est formidable c'est
l'invention du langage et la façon dont
il remplit qui qui aucun des mots qui le
prononce le Siri et c'est il est il est
vraiment il est vraiment formidable il y
a mais en même temps j'ai pas moi j'ai
une je comprends pas très bien j'ai un
problème avec la grande comédie
populaire française c'est-à-dire où est
passé la 7e compagnie la folie des
grandeurs les visiteurs qui sont
présentés souvent comme des chefs j'ai
autant certains des choses où ça
fabuleux ou la panthère rose il y a une
élégance il y a eu un brio etc dans des
grandes comédies américaines ou
italiennes avec la Grande Comédie
Française populaire j'ai toujours un
problème et celui-là évidemment ce film
ci résout plus le problème que la
plupart il y a plus d'inventions plus
d'images chaque plan il y a une petite
idée quoi ça c'est vrai voilà mais enfin
j'ai pas trouvé ça d'une beauté
plastique comme on le dit des cadrage
les plans sont merveilleux là
ton journal c'est fait le héros cette
semaine de d'un nouveau chef-d'œuvre
cinématographique signé
Debbouze évidemment plein de pages oui
oui plein de pages bah ils ont aimé moi
je je m'apprêtais à ne pas le voir parce
que j'avais déjà loupé le premier
épisode parce que je savais même c'était
Zidi hein mais je t'ai pas tout à fait
sûr que ça me plaise mais comme j'ai
reçu un coup de fil de Martine de rabody
maintenant d'y aller je baille toujours
à Martine donc j'y suis allé et alors et
alors et ben donc je sais pas si
vraiment ce film là est une pure
merveille c'est que l'autre était alors
une unité absolue quand même oui tu peux
confirmer là-bas il y avait que
Vercingétorix qui était pire
non voilà il y a deux trois trucs à
Édouard BA qui est bien il y a Djamel on
l'a dit il y a Darmon qui est assez
drôle il y a il y a le personnage aussi
de Itinéris qui fait rire deux trois
fois parce que c'est c'est moi elle
parle comme un comme comme un petit
rêveur donc ça c'est assez drôle mais
moi j'ai trouvé surtout ça extrêmement
lent c'est-à-dire c'est vrai il y a des
gags pratiquement à chaque plan ou
presque mais attends je trouve ça très
répétitif il y a un peu l'entoune quoi
donc je n'ai pas compris autiste
l'inventeur de l'ascenseur
je trouve ça je comprends je trouve que
la Grande Vadrouille pardon c'est une
question mais c'est sympa et c'est plus
drôle à ce moment-là dans le genre
comique français sans même parler des
des grands films au cas de Michel vient
faire allusion c'est-à-dire black
Édouard c'est et certains la même chose
bien entendu je trouve ça très très
petit voilà alors quand je pense que ça
dépend c'est une fortune pas si loin
dans l'enthousiasme que tu es cher
concert et confrères je suis un tout
petit peu en retrait voilà Daniel
non non là ce qui est sérieux c'était
effectivement de juger l'ensemble de la
presse depuis une semaine c'est vrai
totalement il y a une valeur une espèce
de valeur d'entraînement moi ce qui me
frappe et ce qui me choque effectivement
on répète à l'envie c'est le film le
plus cher de l'histoire du cinéma
français oui et pas très bien oui et ce
film
occupe 900 écrans en France c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'y a plus aucune place pour les
les petits films il y a quelques gros
film américain
et donc effectivement c'est choquant 900
900 écrans c'est choquant mais je trouve
que d'une certaine façon heureusement
ça les vaut je veux dire bon ça ça va
effectivement avoir un succès fou il
faut pas non plus qu'il y ait un retour
de bâton et que on soit tellement
non non si nous aussi on se tribune oui
oui bon non je trouve que c'est
effectivement tenu par Alain Chabat je
trouve jusqu'à la Chabat est un monsieur
qui a beaucoup de talents qui arrivent
effectivement à retrouver beaucoup plus
bien sûr que Zidi mais véritablement
l'esprit de la bande dessinée l'esprit
de de Goscinny et Verseau l'esprit de
Goscinny c'est ces espèces de décalage
d'anachronisme de de retour à une
actualité
seconde degré et bon je vais dire ça
remplit sa mission Cléopâtre mission
réussie alors effectivement c'est pas le
grand chef-d'oeuvre annoncé à
l'extérieur mais c'est agréable c'est
assez rigolo effectivement moi j'aime
bien le traitement d'Astérix et Obélix
c'est-à-dire clavier et Depardieu traité
comme une espèce d'icône resteront on
est respectueux c'est plus les les
grandes stars c'est plus les grandes
vedettes mais on les salue on ne les
méprise pas ils ont des rôles à leur
hauteur non mais je trouve que c'est
exactement
je trouve que c'est une et que shabbat
entre César est très très rigolo que
Bellucci est belle
elle est très belle j'aime à te
l'entendre dire tu vois quand tu veux
non non moi je trouve que effectivement
c'est pas un grand chef-d'oeuvre c'est
exactement une mission accomplie et
voilà c'est ça illustre à la Rio
je trouve que c'est un film le succès
considérable de ce film me semble-t-il
vient d'une surprise et d'un soulagement
c'est-à-dire que depuis une dizaine
d'années je le dis franchement c'était
habitué à voir des films annoncés comme
les comiques du siècle qui était
sinistre ou en uriait jamais je veux
prendre pour exemple les visiteurs et en
particulier le secondaire qui était un
monument notre tristesse le premier pas
vrai oui mais ça fait plus de 10 ans et
depuis les anges gardiens étaient
absolument sinistraux enfin première
Astérix et la brusquement on voit deux
valeurs qui se rej c'est à dire d'une
part un film comique d'autre part du
rire alors évidemment on était
extrêmement plus apparaît tout simple et
encore faut-il savoir le faire explosif
moi je pense toujours que je pense
toujours que dans les films comiques
sont meilleurs quand les gens qui les
font sont drone ce que les producteurs
semblent
les missions
un mec il parle parce que il y a des
rires en bois
donc c'est des gens et les nuls on peut
penser ceux qu'on veut des nuls au
cinéma mais ils avaient fait un petit
film s'appelait la cité de la peur qui
était un film très efficace très amusant
et qui était plein de ces films comiques
qui faisait rire donc les gens y vont il
y a des tas d'idées je pense que la
meilleure idée du film c'est tout
simplement d'en faire une bonne
adaptation littéraire c'est-à-dire que
shabbat qui est un modeste est allé
prendre un excellent scénario comique de
Goscinny sous le peut être sous le
contrôle de Tchernia qui est qui était
un ami de Goscinny et qui participe au
film et il a simplement mis en œuvre un
scénario qui marche